And when live, what's up, heavyweight
champion of the world. How does that feel?
Man said amazing. You
know, it's a big blessing.
I'm just happy this is, it seem real.
It's still, yeah, of course it's real.
Uh, for the first few weeks, the
first few days I was pinching myself.
See it fills, fills a dream
or nothing, but you know,
I'm just really blessed to be here. I
want a big blessed honorable situation.
Right. You got soaps, like how many weeks
out did you find out about the fight?
Um, I think it was like a month,
a month and two weeks. Wow.
Month and two weeks. I messaged JD
Hearns I told him, you know what,
give me the opportunity and what
do you know, you message back?
Me and my girl were just all happy.
Like whoa. That was crazy. Wow.
And you were already in
camp, right? [inaudible]
so like it wasn't like they
close you out of shape? No,
it was after my fight against, uh,
Alexander to trinkle. Oh, that's right.
How much time did you
have off to recover? Um,
I just took like a week and
a half off fell. That's nine.
I went back to the gym and I, we'll
just ready and loose. So it was,
it couldn't have happened in a
perfect time. That's amazing. Um,
do you like it like that where you
just experienced a big fight so you're
already kind of used to the being
in the ring, being on television,
the whole moment of it all and then
boom, it happens again right afterwards.
Yeah, of course. You know,
cause I was already loose,
I was already in fight mode.
So especially from, uh,
having the heavyweight
champion title, you know,
I'm the opportunity to get that. It was
amazing. It was incredible fight, man.
It was incredible, man. Thank
you. It was really amazing.
What was amazing was when you got
dropped, you kept your composure,
you got up and then he tried to move
in for the kill and then you started
landing bombs on him and dropped him.
And I remember jumping off the
bed while I was watching. Oh Shit.
It was wild man fight. It was
my first time getting dropped.
And you know what? I'm, I don't feel
super hurt, you know, because I have,
when I got dropped,
he hit me with the a good right
hand and I took it like a champ.
But I got a man and I just throwing bombs.
You have fluid punches, man. I mean
it's, it's really interesting to watch.
You're so efficient. Like
the way you throw punches,
you're not like grunting
and fucking digging.
Like there's a lot of guys that you see,
there's a tremendous amount of energy
that's expended every time they throw
punches. But you man, your punches
just coming bunches, they just pop.
You just fire them on nations.
The combinations that we'd be working
at in the gym, many rollerblades.
That's why I had a trainer who throws a
lot of combinations as good at a working
speed. So I think we click
really good together. Well,
it's such a big asset for heavyweights
because most heavyweights,
they're throwing big bombs and they're
looking for that one punch. Yeah.
And you just pile them on man. And
you throw them at all these angles.
And especially when you get
in tight with dudes, you know,
like w when you're in tight
with dudes in these dogfights,
your punches are coming at these different
angles and so fluid is beautiful to
watch, man. Thank you man.
Especially with these big guys.
I love fighting bigger guys. You know,
some one time I s I fought a guy that was
shorter than me and it was Kinda hard.
So imagine me pressuring bigger guys
and throwing these combinations at works
for me. Really good. It does.
And you're the first ever Mexican
heavyweight champion of the world.
Thanks to God. It's crazy man.
I mean you are in the same
league as a Cain Velasquez,
the first ever in UFC heavyweight
champion that was Mexican. Yeah,
I mean that's a, that's just
an incredible honor man.
Thanks man.
Have water shirt that the love you
must be getting from all the meaning.
Oh my gosh, I can't even go to the
store without taking so many pictures.
People on a lines, they get off, uh,
like say if I'm in a
drive through somewhere,
they get off of their car and tries
to take pictures. But it's a blessing,
you know? I really appreciate it. All my
fans, all the supporters. It's amazing,
man. You know what was really cool was
the post-fight press conference when you
talking about it, you're like,
damn, you know, we made it.
And you were just saying,
we're seven. My mom. Yeah.
Tell your mom that was
beautiful. Yeah, I can,
because a lot of people don't know
that we're, we're struggling a lot of,
even before this fight, you know,
and I'm going through a lot of the stuff
with a top rank with Bob Barron of me
not getting a lot of fights, a waiting,
waiting because I had one
more fight left with them,
so they didn't want to let me go,
so I had to pay my pay it off.
So now, yeah, everything
turned around so quick.
Sorry Bob. I fucked up. Yeah,
well there's a lot to do too.
We're not interested in
fighting you. You know? Um,
I had seen it was one of those things
where you were incredibly talented and
incredibly skilled, but you
didn't have the biggest name yet.
So there wasn't like a
lot of money in it yet,
but there was a giant risk and
a lot of insiders were very,
very aware of this. You know,
guys who really followed boxing were
very aware of this and coming into that
fight,
like I talked to a lot of people that are
like big boxing fans and they're like,
that dude is alive dog.
That's a live dog. Like,
I mean for sure. Anthony
Joshua was a bad motherfucker.
He's a big giant muscular dude. It looks
like a dinosaur. But they were like,
Andy Ruiz is alive dog.
He could win that fucking,
it's because when they see me, they're
like, oh, look at this chubby kid, man.
He's going to get tired really fast.
He's just going to get knocked out.
But the real people that know about
boxing, they know the skills that I have,
the movement. Yeah, I could get a
little bit more fit and I'm more leaner,
you know, get the, the um,
like the extra fat turning into
muscle. I love to do that, you know,
but the thing is people love you because
you're kind of Chubby. Cause I, I'm me.
Well it's also you, you
like, you like, Hey,
you know people that like go to the
beach and don't want to take their shirt
off. You're like, fuck man, Andy
Ruiz is kinda built like me shit.
And he's the champion of the world. Yeah,
give, give these bad guys confident.
You know, it makes a big deal. Like
you remember when Butter Bean Pot,
potter bean was obviously
never a champ, but you know
[inaudible] because he was as big
fat guy. I would fuck people up.
You know what? I took a picture with a
butter being when I was at like thing.
I was like five years old,
six years old and the Quanah,
he fought over there and he
was a big guy, man, big guy.
He was a tank man.
That dude had some fucking pie where
he made everybody a starch. People,
you know, he really couldn't
go past four or five rounds,
but he would put a fucking beating
on you for four rounds. See,
when Johnny Knoxville from a,
that crazy asshole decided to hey,
they made him bleed or something
on that God. But he, they,
he let him punch him
for some crazy reason.
He decided to try to box with
butter beans, sprained them. It was,
this was not good. Don't
do that to people, man. Now
I'm going to sign a waiver.
So you're sitting pretty right now, man.
I mean, you're at the top of the heap.
You're the champ and you are the most
popular champ right now because you're the
guy who pulled off the giant upset
over the Olympic gold medalist,
the fucking the man, Anthony Joshua,
you knock him out and like th everyone
is sitting there chomping at the bit.
There's wilder who's, you know,
probably the greatest knockout artists
in the history, the heavyweight division.
And then there's Tyson
fury and Tyson fury.
And while they're trying to figure it out,
and then Tyson fury is now
in a different organization.
It's a hard to make the matches work
now. It's like what happens next for you?
You know? Um,
what's gonna be next is the rematch
against me and Anthony. Joshua,
we're still negotiating. Um, but
there's definitely going to be there.
We matched this year.
Exciting fight. Uh, but yeah,
but a wilder, you know, uh,
while they're wearing me and
him are on the same team.
I had a little interview with him over
there at the pack-out fight and really
cool dude. He's very
cool. He's really cool.
We would respect each other and um,
but that'll be a good fight, you know,
between me and him. I love that. Well,
I mean, people knew who he was before,
but God damn that Tyson fury fight put
him on the map. What anything raising.
I was really glad I was
there too. I was like, man,
I want to be in that position.
I want to be championed and kind of
motivating me, you know, there well,
you know, and then his, the fight
with Brazil afterwards where he,
he flat lined that one punch. He's an
interesting guy, man. He's so interesting.
You know,
his story that he didn't even start boxing
until he was like 20 something years
old and he really started
doing it because of a daughter,
because the daughter has medical
issues. Got into the Olympic team,
won a bronze medal a year and a half in
a boxing. That's crazy. Yeah, it's nuts.
But he's blessed, you know? Yeah.
Blessed. Like you man. I mean,
this is it. It's gotta be a crazy
feeling now like six months ago,
you're this struggling boxer, you know,
trying to make ends meet, you know,
working your way up, very respected.
We don't have that big name yet.
And then boom, you get the
opportunity of all opportunities.
I think that's what I need is just the
opportunity and be hungry, you know,
from having nothing to wanting
to want, uh, something, you know,
in life. It, it's a big motivation.
Especially with me. I have five kids,
so damn. Hello. I'm 29. Wow.
Five kids started early.
I know, but Mexican style,
Mexican style, definitely. Well, hey man,
your five kids are sitting pretty now,
man. Yeah, that's a
beautiful name. So you a,
there was a rematch that
is in negotiation. Now, how
much can you tell us? Um,
that is going to be in December
sometime. December. Uh, um,
uh, there's going to be, there's going
to come out pretty soon. You know, I,
I did tell you about telling anybody.
No, don't send it to the cameras are off.
Yeah. Um, but it's going to be this
year. It's going to be an exciting fight.
Me and Anthony, Joshua
rematch. Uh, but, um, the,
the words are gonna come out soon.
Where's it gonna be at? If anything,
I'll message you and be like, Oh,
you already know actually. Well, um,
so now going into this rematch,
is there anything that you're going to
do differently? I mean, um, you know,
obviously now that he's well aware
you're a big threat, you know,
he's going to think about you. I mean,
I'm sure he was aware you were threat
before, but when you stopped him,
you became the first guy to beat him. I
mean that, I mean, that changes history,
that thing. What we're
going to do. Uh, um, we're,
we're getting a big house over
there in Mexico, somewhere in the,
in the nowhere is, you know, so we're
going to have a close suited, uh, uh,
camp, you know, close camps.
So we're just going to be
really focused for this fight.
We're not underestimating him
or anything. Um, you know,
it was just got to work
hard and do it again.
She'll show people what
I'm capable of. Now.
How much changes now that you're
the champ, do you have, um,
do you change anything in your camp and
as far as your strength and conditioning
as far as nutrition or, um, as long
as we have all the team, you know,
the stuff that we need and the nutrition
is the chef, uh, um, the coaches,
you know, the, all the, all the stuff
that I need to, to win this fight,
especially training, you know, that
that's the main thing and trainings thing,
discipline and, and, um,
you know, praying to God.
Now I'm coming into the fight
with Joshua the first time.
Did you have a nutritionist? Did you
have a strength and conditioning coach?
And I did have one. Um, the plan was
not to lose too much weight, you know,
because the guy's really big, you know,
I want it to be heavy so I could
carry his weight and you know,
and it worked for my favor. But I think
the main thing that I'm going to do,
I might do a little bit of ways
just to tighten up a little bit. Uh,
but just they busy. That's the main
thing. Do you worry about like give,
it's not broke, don't fix it.
Like there have been guys before that
have made changes in the way they prepare
and those like maybe fuck with their
confidence or they didn't feel as good.
They didn't, they didn't
perform the same way. No,
I don't think we're going to be changing
too much of that stuff. You know,
as long as they're, it's training,
we have the good sparring, just,
just exactly what we
did for the last fight.
I think that's where we're going
to be doing this more intense. Now.
Do you have a guy that monitors
your heart rate? Do they,
did they take like logs of like what your
resting heart rate is when you get up
in the morning and your
heart rate variability and
all that kind of shit? Nah,
they don't, they don't do that. I'm Kinda
just old school, old school, you know,
work hard, wake up, run, train. Uh,
he good for like four or five days and
we have our little cheap meals, you know,
but you know, just, just have
a happy camp that, you know,
this is heavy weight camp. Like attire,
battery. Yeah. Heavyweight camps.
Nice weight cutting. Now what kind
of food they have you eating? Um,
right now I'm just, uh, just eating
like, you know, uh, sandwiches,
uh, sandwich steaks. Yeah. I just ate
a sandwich before I came on. So, well,
the beautiful thing about
beating heavyweights,
you don't have to worry about your weight,
but it's in terms of optimal performance,
like when your chef has you in camp, oh,
when will come and they feed
everything chicken. Me. Uh,
I try not to eat too much. Me, you
know, it takes too long to digest.
I get constipated, can
shit comfortable. But,
um, everything, no vegetables,
a lot of white rise. They tell,
they tell me not to eat too much white
rice, but I like white rice. Now.
Do they have you taking supplements
or anything like that? You know what,
for this fight I wasn't taking a lot
of slip them as just multivitamins. Um,
something to get me
through the training. Um,
yeah basically. And what kind of strength
of conditioning should they have?
You do and you running,
you running, sweating, um,
doing explosive stuff. Uh, a lot
of made work, a lot of millwork.
I think that's one of my favorite
things at the gym. Sparring,
beating people up and doing
millwork. Yeah, of course.
Right now you, you had an
extensive amateur career too, man,
which is a think a lot of like how
you're so well-schooled you know,
that that helped me a lot, you know. Um,
I first started training when I was six
years old and now I trained for a whole
year and when I was 70 years old,
I had my first amateur fight. Um,
I was always this big
Chubby kid where, uh,
there wasn't people at my age at
that weight. So I always had a fight.
Bigger guys and no older
guys. So my first fight I won,
but they gave it to the other guy at 12
years old, finding a seven year old. So,
but I got robbed, I got robbed. I
feel I dabbed your first fight and I,
and I had the video too. Oh,
just put that shit online. Yup.
Let the Internet decide. Wow. So
you first fight at seven years old.
That's incredible, man. That's,
there's no substitute for that guys
who get into combat sports young.
That's the guys who have what I was
talking about that you possessed before.
That sort of fluidity. The efficiency
to punches. It's like your,
you develop throwing punches. I, it's
all muscle memory type of, you know, um,
a lot of male work and she's
working hard, man, working hard.
And this is a sport that I
love and I've been doing.
This is the only thing that I know. So
thank God that it paid off, but I just,
it's, it's such an amazing
story. I love a story like that.
It's such a rocky story, such as
Cinderella story and I Cinderella,
it's amazing. Well, yeah,
everybody underestimated me there.
They're just waiting for me to, to
get knocked down. And then when they,
when they see me get knocked
down, they're like, oh.
And it's crazy that the announcers were
saying, oh, Anthony's a great finisher.
Look at how he's in, finish
him and what do you know?
I ended up getting them with
the, with the hook. Yeah.
It was crazy how many times you watched
the fight? Um, probably like 30 times,
30 times. And I still got
more, more to see, you know,
because when he come in with the
uppercut and the hook, um, I was Kinda,
I was kind of being on a
lazy mode, you know? Uh,
I think I need to put my geared
up more and move ahead more. Well,
he's a big powerful motherfucker,
but he's an outside fighter.
He likes to fight on the outside
and drop big power punches.
And that's where it became apparent
that like when you're in the dog fight,
when you guys are in tight, you have that
advantage. The fluidity in efficiency.
And I think it's, I think it was the
speed that I kind of messed them up,
you know, and I'm not, I'm not just
the one, two, three fighter, a puncher,
you know, and I try to throw more than,
than one or two punches. So no dude,
you know, throw hailstorms shit
coming away from all kinds of angles.
It's awesome man. So you're in this
amazing position now, um, when you're,
you're headed into this fight, how long
did it take to negotiate the rematch?
I'm sure you had some sort of
a contract clause, right? Yeah,
we had a contract clause, uh, which has
been going back and forth, you know,
with my team and their team. Cause they
were trying to get you to go to England.
Yeah. But now I want to say it in
America, but in, there's some, we don't,
we can't say what's happening.
I love to have it back over there at
the Madison Square Garden, you know,
loves to run it back.
And [inaudible] how about the staples
center and the Staples Center?
That's what I said to and
when one of the interviews,
but for Vegas Move Vegas would
have been great too. Yeah, right.
But wherever it is is going to be an
amazing fight and amazing venues. So,
but tune in is there, the
announcement is going to be in soon.
Now is this gonna be on design
again on the zone? Beautiful. Um,
it's so nice. You could
just watch it on app. Yeah,
we're watching your phone and
watching a laptop. And um,
when you see the rest of the heavyweight
division meeting, what a crazy,
exciting time for boxing. Lauzon
comes in these waves, right?
And we're like this waves of awesome
shit happening right now as a hot wave.
Canelo's hot. You know, Manny just
won the title at 40 years old,
you know, triple g and canal, they're
talking about having another fight.
It's so amazing right now. It's
like boxing is on fire. That is,
you know, and I'm just blessed to be
in there and in the top 10, you know,
and having the unified heavyweight
champions. But, you know, uh,
I'm willing to fight anybody
as soon as I, um, when the,
the rematch, I'm willing to fight Tyson
fury or wilder or anybody, you know,
that's all. Well, listen,
there's never been a time that I can
recall where there's four legitimate
heavyweight champions that everybody
thinks of. Like, look, Anthony,
Joshua could have been the
man, you know, Tyson fewer.
He could be the man while
there could be demand.
You could be the man who's the
fucking man. It's like, no one knows.
It's not like during the Tyson era,
it was like Tyson and everybody else
was just, just waiting to get murked.
You know, like there's been times
where there was a standout fighter,
but when you, when Joshua beat Klitschko,
it was apparent that Joshua was the guy.
But then as wilder started piling
up bodies, it's like, damn,
maybe Wilder's the guy and then
Tyson fury comes back, you know?
And like a lot of people had written
Tyson fury off after the Klitschko fight.
They were like, you know,
he kind of went crazy,
almost committed suicide and all these
mental health problems and now he seem
super happy and healthy.
And so it's this incredible,
incredible time for boxing where you
have like in terms of star power and in
terms of like the public interest,
I can't recall a time in my life with
has been for dudes who were at the top of
the heap like this. Yeah, a Tyson
phrase, a good guy. It's, you know,
I love his personality, his
energy. And you know what if I, if,
if I want to see that fight again
while during fury, you know?
And those are really good fight.
I think it was really close.
If Walter wouldn't have knocked
him down in the last round,
I think Tyson freer was winning
in my eyes. I think so too.
And I think you could make an argument
that he still won even though he got
knocked down twice in the
five. Yeah. It's still,
you make a good argument that
he still won the decision.
I know a lot of people think he did,
but I didn't have a problem with the
decision just because of action does not
end the way wilder knocked him down
and that final well like what the fuck?
How did he get up? That was,
what was crazy like when while there
like two was a stomach crosses throat and
with Oh fuck, it's over
and he's shaking his head.
He thought it was off and then Tyson
fury just rises from the dead like a
fucking Zombie. It's just as crazy man
in the heavyweight division, you know?
It only takes one punch to change the
whole game, the whole, the whole fight,
you know? And that's the beauty of
it. It is the beauty of it. Now.
What is it like,
like getting accustomed to all this
recognition now I know you've got this new
ice, you got an ar hanging
phone spending a little,
that heavyweight champion. Shailene
jeweler. Yeah man. Dude, your,
I mean your whole life is like shifted.
Like what does that feel like? Shit,
it feels good. You know, just get in the
stuff that I always wanted. You know,
seeing a lot of famous, uh, people
having nice stuff, you know,
and uh,
thanks to God and now I could just
get it from myself and from my family,
from my kids. My mom. I'm gonna call you
driving now. Um, I have a Rolls Royce.
You stepped right up. You
didn't even fuck around.
You didn't even try BMW first.
Nah, I already had that before.
What were you driving before you
won the title? Um, I had a Porsche.
I had a Porsche Panamera oh, those
are nice. But it's our roles wise. No,
Rolls Royce is a king car.
You know what the car that I love
right now and I bought from my,
from my fiance Julie. Uh,
it's the new g wagons.
It's 2019 so beautiful shine.
My wife is one of those.
Yeah, the other shit. She was lucky.
Those are dope man. That's a crazy car.
It's, they redesigned it. They made it
so that the old ones, they had like a,
that old truck suspension with the live
rear and front axles and it was kind of
bumpy and shit. I love
it, man. When you move it,
when the car moves that like the
seats hug you, that's a tank too.
Yeah. Those doors we a
thousand pounds. It's crazy.
We shut those things like a
bank vault, you know? Yeah.
But there's something about a Rolls Royce
man that's like a suitable car for a
champ. You know, you run around
the room. All my dream car man,
my dream car I even had pictures of
before. I wasn't even in any of that.
Nothing. I used to have
pictures on my, on my,
on my wall of other cars that I wanted
a Lamborghini, Rolls Royce, you know,
just dreaming big. Right. And that's
what I tell a lot of these kids,
managers that dream big
have, have 'em right.
Something that you want in life and just
keep, keep praying for it, you know,
keep wishing for it and it will
come true. You work hard. Yeah.
If you work hard. Some people
just want to wish, no. Yeah.
They got to work hard. There's
a lot of shit involved. Yeah.
Do you use any sort of
a sports psychologist or
anything like that? Um, no,
not really. No. Just
motivation. My kids, uh,
um, you know, just a person that wants
to do betters and to do better. Right.
And so when you are preparing
for a fight, do you,
um, do you ever have moments
where you, you know, you'll,
you'll find yourself feeling down
or you find yourself not, yeah,
there's mental place now. There's
a lot of times like that, you know,
because I'm missing home. I'm like,
man, I want to go with my kids.
I want to go with my girl. Oh,
I'm, I'm, I'm mad man. I haven't,
I haven't fucked or nothing, so I'm
fucking angry. And um, you know,
stuff like that. That's what a lot
of boxers go through, you know,
because this is a lonely sport, you know,
this was a one man sport and you know,
you got to do everything on
your own and not on your own.
But when you go to the gym, you have
routine, but you just after the gym as,
as what you do, you know, I
usually just rest, watch movies.
I'm trying to go to show, find a show,
just relax, just chill out. Do A,
get regular massage or anything. Yep.
I get massages, um, from ar therapy,
uh, from La. Uh, he hooks it up like
every, I probably when I'm in camp,
I'll get one like to two
times a week, three times.
So basically it's normal stuff, just
normal strength and conditioning food.
It's the grind of camp is something
that boxers always complained about.
That's like one thing is
this to the day in, day out,
just hard work constantly.
You know what sex for for a lot of the
fighters too is going in there and you
know, your coach wants you away,
you after training every fucking
time and you're like, man.
And it's crazy. But you know, I
was just working hard. It's, it's,
it's, everything's in a payoff.
What did they like to keep you at?
Like what weight did they
like to keep you out? Um,
I think like at two 55 to 50, that's
where you feel like you're your best.
I'm at my best at two 50
by two 50. But I gained to,
what did I wait like two 67
for Joshua really purpose.
Just because he saw me. Huh?
Yeah, I kind of worked out.
It definitely worked out. Now what
did you do differently? Um, nothing.
No, it was good. Just I'm
more portion, you know,
a little bit more portion and I was just
happy through all this camp. You know,
I was just focused, motivated. Uh,
I kept telling everybody
that I'm going to win,
that I'm going to pull out
the upset and you know,
just having those good vibes inside
you. Uh, and the fun camp, you know,
it was fun. I enjoyed the camp a lot.
The only thing that people worry about
when someone finds success and you know,
obviously Tyson is the best example
of it because he's documented in his
documentary and he talks about all the
time was how things got out of control.
Once he became famous, I was,
things just went off the rails and he
just lost his fucking mind. How do you,
how do you prevent that from
happening and you were weeds.
I think just having the right
people around you. You know,
having the right people around you that
want to do good and want you to do good,
you know, I'm bringing you good
opportunities, you know, stuff like that.
And you know, I'm a, I'm a family man.
I'm always with my kids, with my fiances.
So, um, that's one of the
big blessings that I have.
And if that would've happened, I think
my dad will grab me by the throat, like,
what the fuck are you
doing? He's always on me.
So you seem like a real down to Earth
Guy, which helps a lot, you know?
I mean that, that really does,
it's the dudes that have feeling like
sometimes the ego is what gets you to the
dance because you believe you are
the baddest motherfucker of all time.
But then once you are there
and the challenge is met,
then there's no other challenges
in front of you, like with Tyson.
And each fight is kind of like a done
deal before it happens and you just start
getting tigers and doing crazy shit,
you know, recently with tigers. Yeah.
Nah. Um, then the main thing just
remain humble, you know? Um, I,
um, I was praying for this
opportunity for so long,
so I'm still gonna continue to keep
praying and thanking God for all these big
blessings that he gave me and you know,
just continue to work hard and
enjoy my family to the fullest.
And you've got a good crew of
dudes with you too. You can tell.
I know this is you're saying this the
biggest entourage that the hat and I
never, I never rolled
everybody's ever brought in here.
I never wrote with a lot of entourage
and not just with a few of my best
friends, you know, friends,
close friends that were from high
school and some of my cousins and that's
awesome. Stuff like that.
Just family who know you.
He's actually known you
from the beginning. Now I'm
this new found celebrity,
like are they giving you like there's
other distractions that come your way,
like, like movie type offers and
television shit. You know what?
I did my first commercial, uh, for
sweat away exhales and, and uh,
it's a Masco brand. What is it? A
sweat o x sweat o x sweat away. It's a,
it's a drink, you know,
like, uh, like pedia light,
but it's a Mexican version and it
was fun, man. It was really fun.
I loved doing commercials. Have you
been to Mexico since you one? I have.
You remember I met the
president of Mexico.
I went to Los Pinos and that was
amazing man. Um, um, that is Lopez.
He's the president for, for med school.
Amazing guy is a wild being in Mexico
was the first ever Mexican heavyweight
champion and it was super wild.
So many, so many fans, you know,
little kids, uh, of, um,
all types of sort of people come
in my way and it's just crazy how,
how they react, you know, how they react
or screaming. Like it's crazy, man.
I was, must be the,
the wildest thing about this is the shift
in how people perceive you versus just
a few months ago and now like
you're the fucking man. It's,
it's weird, right? It's crazy.
Does that mean what does, what,
what goes on in your head while
all this has happened? Um,
that this is just the beginning. You know,
this is just the beginning and you know,
I don't wanna I don't
want to lose the title.
So the main thing I could just gotta
stay focused and get prepared for the
rematch. You know, cause there's more
work to be done. So, and um, you know,
I want to be the Mexican Rockies so I
want to continue to keep winning and
defending all my titles. That's beautiful.
Now Joshua is the first fight and
so this will take place in December.
And given if you win, what would you
like to, who would you like to face next?
Cause it looks like it's going to be a
while before they could sort out Tyson
fury and Deontay wilder. Um,
because of contractual shit.
Uh, when I, when and, and Sealskin
I went for the rematch. Uh,
I love to fight Tyson fury man sizing
fury. I know wilder Wilder's there too.
He has the belt that, that I want,
you know, cause I want the WBC bell.
Why do you want that belt? Because
I'll be undisputed if I have that bell,
you know, I have all the belts. I'm
in the heavyweight division and I'll,
I'll be the new king. Do you have not?
You have WBA I have the WBA.
WBO I beo and IBF. Damn.
I know. Damn, that's crazy. I
should've brought him to man. Shut up.
Do what you just have
laid out on your bed? No,
they're actually in my at
Dad's house. They're actually,
I thought my dad's house must be bizarre.
Just looking at them. Right? They are,
man. It's, I was crying, man. Like I
said, I was still pinching myself for,
for weeks. I can only imagine.
I would imagine it's getting the
last years before really, really,
really sinks in. So, uh,
Tyson fewer seems to you to be like the
best matchup after that size. Inferior.
I think that he's, well, he's one of the
biggest names out there, you know? Um,
I, I liked Dylan, Dylan White, so,
you know, he was coming up, but um,
he got caught up with stop it. Uh, what
did he get? What did he get caught with?
I don't know. I think
it was PD or something,
some sort of performance enhancing.
I don't know why they do that.
I know why they want to win. Shit. I,
you don't need it man. Look at me. I'm,
it doesn't look like if I take anything.
And I was just on natural. Well,
you're consistent and even
though you carry body fat,
you're always in great shape. You know,
you never have a problem with fatigue.
I have a six pack under my bed.
It's in the valley somewhere. Yeah,
I mean that's deceptive. You know,
there's quite a few fighters like that
that you look at them on the outside and
you can get real confused, you know?
But you have always been consistent.
Like you had a consistent amateur
career, consistent professional career.
Some fighters just like they,
maybe they just feel like they
need something else, you know?
They just don't feel like they're
doing enough and they want it.
They want a shortcut. It's
usually, it's usually a bad sign,
you know? And in today's
climate it's, look, there's,
there's Vata testing and
there's the best, you know,
that was my first time getting tested.
And by Vida and they're fucking
strict man. They go there,
they'll go look for you wherever you're
at, at your house, at the gym, anywhere.
And um, they take blood
out, piss out. I liked it.
Yes. Um, I think it's the best way.
And you Sada is what works with the
UFC. Very similar, same sort of deal.
They wake you up six o'clock
in the morning, hey buddy,
time to find out what's up, you know,
and they've caught a
lot of people that way.
They caught a lot of people and it's
great. It cleans up the sport, you know,
I mean this, uh, this is a dangerous,
dangerous sport and when
people are taking things, they,
there's a potential that they could hit
you when they wouldn't be able to hit
you without it. And I mean, this is a
something that we all want to avoid.
We all know,
avoid anything that could potentially
mean it's already a dangerous enough,
some balls out. It's already trying to
kill each other and all that. Yeah. Yeah.
So Dillon white is, I mean, how long
they suspended him for? Um, I'm not sure.
I seen it on Instagram, but you
know, things happen. But you know,
hopefully it gets clean and, or we don't
know what really happened. You know,
maybe there was a team side of that
puts something in it or we don't know.
Yeah. It could be PR. When we
catch this a lot with the UFC,
we're guys buy a supplement at like
a vitamin store and it's tainted.
Or even like a diet one holiday.
They been that soon. Yeah. Yeah.
Anything that has like a diarrhetic
things along those lines. Yeah,
it's a as a shame. But you know,
if they're not using Vada
testing and they get caught,
then they're just dumb. Cause
then it doesn't, it means that,
that's what I was kind of scared. You
know, fighting over there at the UK.
We don't know what they're gonna be
letting our Anthony Joshua be taking or
whatnot or, I don't know,
take some shit. I don't know.
Tell you what she looks like. He
does. He does. He looks like it.
But it looks like what you would
think a movie fighter would look like.
You know, like he's, he's
just, he's built perfect,
like he's got a perfect body. Like
you wouldn't want to change anything,
you know, like if you're making a
sculpture, like damn nailed it. Yeah.
You know, but that, I don't know if
that's natural. What do you think?
I don't know if he took something,
you know, it didn't work. If he,
if he doesn't wear, if he doesn't
use it for the next fight,
I don't know who knows how the body's
gonna react or if he doesn't have it. So,
or maybe, um,
reacted wrong when he wasn't using it
when I follow him or that's possible.
That's definitely happened before. That's
definitely happened before. You know,
you've seen fighters that look different
because of stricter testing and then
they don't perform the same
way. They have like real proud.
And then also it's confidence.
If you know you've been cheating and
then all of a sudden they take away your
secret weapon and then you just,
you're like, I'm fine, I'm fine,
but you in this little league out. Yep.
So you worried about that? If, if I,
if the fight takes place in
the UK, uh, you know, somewhat,
but it's not going to be over there.
So he's never tested positive before.
Right. He's never have, so
you just gave up the ghost,
you said it's not going to be over there.
So now the people have narrowed
it down. There's 197 countries,
now we know it's not going to be in
England. No, that's not okay. 196.
Yeah, it's uh, in combat sports. I
mean, it's always been a problem.
Performance enhancing drug.
Now everybody's been using
it. A lot of champions,
you know, from the heavyweight division
two, a lot of sure. A lot of people.
Yeah. But I dunno, I don't want to
try it. I don't want to get caught up.
Well, it's,
it's beautiful that you haven't had it
and you can take pride that everything
that you've accomplished is from hard
work and intelligence. Yeah, sure that.
So when you look at the landscape
of boxing, I mean, right now, uh,
what fights are exciting for you?
Um, I want to see that pack out and,
uh, what's his name? Thurman? No. Uh,
um, uh, the guy that fought, uh,
many, um, Mikey Garcia. Oh,
Earl span arrow span or else Penn's
chant like him. He's a bad motherfucker.
Wish the shutdown Garcia like that.
Garcia is a bad motherfucker. He was,
I was over there in Vegas with him.
It was funny. Well, when Garcia look,
I give it up to Garcia cause after that
fight, he's like, that guy is the truth.
Yeah. The guy's the
real deal. And you know,
that's beautiful when a guy doesn't
make excuses and says, hey man, I guys,
he's, everybody knew Earl. Spence
is a bad motherfucker though.
I mean there was no surprise once you
have him fight like the really elite
fighters, I think that's when highest
talents is in a show. Oh sure. Yeah.
I mean it's such a great time for boxing
or Earl spends junior versus Manny
pack. That would be incredible.
Yeah. They're working on it.
Is that what they're working on?
I thought they were working on a rematch
with Thurman. Uh, I don't think so. No.
No. Who wants to see
that? Man, I want to see,
you don't want to say I think
Pacquiao beat his ass. Fuck yeah.
It was crazy when he knocked him
down. The first round was huh? Wow.
I think he got too
confident at the many pack.
Y'All got too confident and he got hit
with punches that he shouldn't have.
You know? And I don't know, I think
Thurman was just surviving the whole time,
but either way he was
connecting really good shots.
He connected with good
shots and then he hits hard.
The crazy thing is Manny is the oldest
ever guy to win the welterweight title.
40 years old.
He's won titles in how many different
weight classes now it's more than eight.
Like 12. I don't know something,
but it's like eight more than eight
different weight classes, which is nuts.
Like who the fuck does that?
And then maintains his power
all the way through it.
He just takes care of himself,
you know. Amaz I am white rice,
whatever it's doing in the Philippines,
so it's amazing. But um, yeah,
that's a great fight. Um,
and then there's Mayweather who shows
up at that fight and talking shit.
And I think that'd be a good fight
against Manny pack young Mayweather. Oh,
watch it. Apparently according to
Khabib number, I bet on it could be.
You've never been better off as
the UFC lightweight champion,
bad Russian motherfucker. He's, um,
he's saying that that Floyd May,
where there's people have been trying
to get him to box him. Uh, that's crazy.
Wow. Floyd made that an easy money
off Conor McGregor. That's crazy.
He probably thinks I do
too. I mean, a crazy, well,
Floyd played that perfectly too.
You don't give Connor like six weeks
to prepare. You know, he, uh, you know,
he took the lion's share of the
money but gave Connor shitload.
He made a lot of money off that fight.
Yeah, man. Where there's smart man,
like I said, having the right
people, which you and that,
that give you good opportunities.
Those are the right people you want
around you. Now, when you were coming up,
um, who are you influenced by?
Like, who are you a big fan of? Um,
of Chavez, you know, all the Mexican
fighters. Moralez Barrera I got to meet.
Um, I've, I read, I was my first
time. It was a good honor over that.
The pack y'all fight. Uh, you
know, my Tyson, um, you know,
all the, all the big guys, all the
Mexican guys as well too. Yeah.
Um, so you're 29, so when you were,
when you first started out, who was, uh,
who was big? Fernando
Vargas hills man. Fernando.
Fernando on the plane was, yeah.
Mesa have the same haircut as him. I,
I painted my, my hair. That was crazy.
Yeah. No, he was a bad motherfucker.
He was a lot of fun to watch.
Didn't he had some reality show he was
doing it to write on it with him and his
family. What is he doing
now? Do you know? Um,
he's training fighters and his kids
too. They're really talented. Um,
we're at in Vegas. Yes. Yeah. Nice. No,
they have really good people. Nice
guys. Oscar de la Hoya. Your fan of his,
yeah. I'll share a little to this. I mean,
there's so many great Mexican fighters.
If you think about one country that
produced a basing boxers, I mean,
Mexico might be the top
of the heap. I mean,
if you really started to
think about it, I think, um,
I think we're missing one champion.
I think we'd have champions in
all the divisions except for one.
I think light heavyweight maybe. Probably
cruiserweight. Cruiserweight I think.
I think so. But you know what?
At least we got the first Mexican
heavyweight champion. Yeah,
that's a field man. So crazy. Those
good, you know, just my saying,
I'm going to be, I'm in
the records, you know, um,
hopefully nobody forgets
my name, but you know,
there's always going to be the first
Mexican heavyweight champion of the world,
especially for my kids. You know, for
them to look up and be like forever. Yeah.
My Daddy never kick your daddy's
ass. It'd be number one. I mean,
you're the first ever does. No one ever
can take that from front. That's it.
Forever. Blessing man. Read the books.
This is what I'd been working for for
so long. You know, my dad pushing me,
embarrassing me and with my friends. Um,
how do you actually just by kicking
me out by telling me, come on.
We had to go try and get the
fuck out of there. I Dunno.
It was crazy, man. My Dad's
always been there behind me,
so I don't think I would've been in this
position if he wasn't in the role of
all this. Is Your Dad a boxer? No,
but his dad used to train fighters and
my heat Kelly. Oh, a long time ago.
I never got to meet him, but, and
he never boxed himself. Um, no.
It was just in the streets. Did
he train? No, he'll just see.
It was just see his, his
dad trained other guys.
I didn't think he had the
discipline. I think it was,
he was more like a hustler basically.
So what was his thought when
you first started finding, well,
he's the one who put me into
it because, yeah, because, um,
I used the destroy your, I used to
destroy everything, all the, the toys, uh,
my mom's stuff, everything. So it
has so much energy as a little kid.
He just took me to, after my first
thing was karate. I tried karate.
I was six years old, didn't like it.
It took too long for action or
whatnot. And he put me in the boxing.
I was six years old. And what do you
know? I fell in love with the sport.
So what do you mean by t
took too long for action? Um,
I think we were practicing too much
or something. I like Katas and Chile.
And the first two weeks
when I went to a boxing gym,
they made me spar in the kick, kick the
shit out of me, man. They beat me up.
I knew he was seven. I was, no, I
was six and a half. You remember?
Cause I trained a whole year. And so I
turned the right. Um, they beat me up.
They put me this far my first time
and I was bleeding and I told my dad,
you know what? I don't want to fight
no more like that. What do you mean?
You just got to keep training and
you're gonna end up beating everyone up.
And what do you know? A year later
I ended up beating heroin up.
So your nickname came from you fucking
things up as a kid. Fucking things up.
Just showing things.
I could never have a toy or ar or even
like a the game boy or anything for like
more than a week or something cause
I would end up breaking it. Right.
So did your parents give you that
nickname? Yeah. That's hilarious.
That's what a great nickname. That
seems like a tough guy nickname.
But then when you find out it's because
you were a little kid and you would
break your toys. That makes
it even better. Every,
not just toys but everything classes.
Uh, I don't know. It was crazy.
So it must be wild for your dad to see
you come up from a six year old kid and
you know,
because of his pushing you and trying
to keep you in there that you eventually
start excelling and winning
amateur fight after amateur fight.
And then he's really happy
manager. They happy. And, um,
uh, like I said, he's really
happy. He's really blessed.
He's over here and over there
just enjoying life as well.
Now when you were coming up to,
was their fighter who
style you tried to emulate,
was there anyone that like really
stood out for you? You know,
I sparked a lot of guys in the hill.
All of them telling me that I have, uh,
my own type of style. You know,
they tell me that I have a calm
different style than, than everyone else.
And you know, I kinda, I like that would,
that is one of the beautiful things about
boxing and all martial arts like this.
A lot of people that don't like that
term martial arts cause they don't think
it's really an art, but it is an art.
I think it's harder man shit from
being in the ground and fighting up.
It's a lot of things you have to learn.
Oh, for mixed martial arts. Yeah.
But I mean even boxing as a martial art
and what I mean is that like the way you
knocked out Joshua, that was
beautiful. It was beautiful for a,
for a person like me who
loves boxing, it was art.
Like you expressed yourself in art.
I mean that's no different than a badass
movie or a rap song or a symphony.
It's art. It's just art with your
fists. And you know, I mean, you saw,
I'm sure you saw that video that
I posted up on my Instagram.
Who was the guy that made that video,
that video where he hits Joshua and Josh,
his soul leaves his body.
He goes on the airplane and I was
a funny man. That guy's amazing.
What is his, what is it? Five, four?
What we're going to find out is it
Instagram and give them some prompts cause
seven 47 right around seven 47 put that,
put that up so we could watch that again.
This, that guy is a goddamn genius.
Cause he didn't just do it with that.
He did it with Deontay versus Brazil.
He gave him a fantasies, a power fist.
This guy does amazing. Animate.
This one's not on Jamie. Oh,
the guy does a amazing,
uh, animation. I mean,
I don't even know how the fuck he does
something like that. I'm what program,
but this was my favorite
play. Play this Jamie
through Joshua through
here. Boom. Look at that. What do you see?
The soldiers leaves his body a blue.
So he gets the roller bag. He's
on the, he's on the escalator.
He gets on the plane and they'll go,
the tweety birds are flying around
his head. That is hilarious man.
That guy's a God damn genius Ray Rod,
seven four seven. Thanks a lot buddy.
No, he's genius. How many
millions of views that should get?
Well I think you re posted it and I
got a lot more views than on his page.
His got like 730 (630) 730-5000
but on mine it was millions.
Yeah, no, it's crazy. He's,
he does a lot of great shit in MMA and
in boxing there's been a lot of that,
right? A lot of memes. Yeah,
I liked it, you know, and
now they have my own ones.
So it's amazing to have
your own one. What?
Like the Mimi's that they put out
above me hitting a Anthony Joshua,
you know, stuff like that. Having me
there and looking at it, I'm just like,
wow, man. It was crazy.
Yeah. Wild. Right. So you,
you didn't emulate anybody when you're
coming up. It's not like Chavez or,
or Barrera. You like tried to imitate
their style or type of course. Yeah,
of course. Like Tyson, you know,
everybody wants to knock
everybody out like Tyson and um,
Chavez always going to the body. You
know, I'm one of the heavyweights.
I like to hit the body of law,
you know, you get them tired. Um,
uh, but like I said, I think I have
my own style, you know, I like,
I like my style. Have you had the
same trainer your entire life? No,
I went through, I learned from a lot of
different trainers. You know, my first,
um, real professional trainer was
Freddy Roach. That's when I man, yeah,
that's when I met Manny Pacquiao, Freddy,
Freddy, me too. Um, great guy. Freddy,
uh, helped me out through my whole
professional career until like the,
my 10th or 12th fight. He had
me. So I learned a lot from him.
Why did you stop training with them?
They send me to Las Vegas, a top rank,
send me over there. Uh, and
then, um, some guy, Jeff,
Jeff's, I'm going to Jeff Gramada, some
big guy was trying to meet over there.
Then we moved from there when we went
to April Sanchez when I felt for the,
for the world title for the WBO again,
parking up in big bear, big Abel.
I was in big bear for I think for like
a month and a half for the Joseph Parker
fight was the only fight you've lost
and there was a close decision. Exactly.
What's your, what was your thoughts
on that fight? Um, you know,
I trained myself for that
fight. A lot of yelling.
A lot of people don't know the,
the training camp that we had,
April Sanchez had like eight different
fighters fighting at that same time.
So he was always flying out.
So he'll just leave us a piece of
paper and be like, you know what,
you guys do this, do that. And on our
own, you know, so that Kinda sucked.
Why did he do that? Uh, I
blew the Hill's obligation to,
to go to the too thin. Yeah. That sucks.
I'm a fan of Abel Sanchez too. He's
a bad motherfucker. Yeah, he sure is.
You know, I appreciate
everything that he's done for me.
He was so knowledgeable.
But for that fight, um,
I think I needed to the right trainer
and moving with many robe Liz and estate
dials. It was the best thing
I could have done, you know,
cause those guys are
really on me. It just two,
two guys just pushing you
and one telling you that one,
you have that and it just good.
You know, it keeps you focused.
And so when Abel was training
you and you train by yourself,
you're up there in big bear and
training by herself. How you going nuts?
I was going Helen as man and
the fuck am I doing up here.
It ain't shit to do
that one movie theater.
I was going back and forth
from my hometown, you know,
cause I live in imperial valley. I live
like, so that's like four hours, right?
Three hours from big bear and I'm,
I was just going back and forth and I
wasn't really focused for that fight,
you know? So, um, a lot of people
don't know that that did you?
The UK? No, I fought them in New
Zealand. Oh Wow. And his hometown too.
Oh Wow. So I think if I would've
been over here with many real bliss,
I definitely would've won. What
was it? Close fight. It was a good,
that was a good fight. What, when you
think about what, what went wrong? I mean,
this is,
it's always so important for a fighter
to have to experience a loss because a
loss sort of lets you know like, hey man,
you don't want this feeling. You know,
and I didn't want to lose no more,
you know, and that's when exactly.
That's when everything went down and me
having child comes with a top rank and,
um, then not letting me go and I'll
Hayman helping me out. How him as the man,
you know, he's a man right now.
And he helped me out through,
through everything to get
me out of the situation and,
and giving me this
opportunity. So, top rank,
did they make you train with able, like
how did, how did that set up? Yeah,
we ended up going over there with
Abel Sanchez. Um, you know, it was a,
it was a good, good idea at first,
but we didn't know it was gonna be like
that Bryant cause he's just got too many
up to five.
There's too many obligations and the
triple g want to believe in him as well.
Right? Yeah. Triple g went with Jacobs,
Anthony and Jacobs or
something like that. Um, my uh,
bat triple, she's a
good fighter. You know,
I seen him over there at the
fights too, so he's a man. Good.
We're good friends now.
He's amazing. And you know,
I'm really interested to see his rematch.
If they tried to do a rubber match,
he's a strong man.
Me and him wrestled over there and
big bear and like literally wrestling.
And this guy picked me up
and she's, he's strongly,
those Russians are a different kind of,
you know, they're strong, different,
they got different tendons
or so, but he's strong now.
He is a bad motherfucker. He's
a really friendly guy too.
He's always smiling and shit.
He's humble his ass. Yeah.
I get along with him really good.
We're over there going crazy
together while we record. Um,
it was just some something that
some, some drill to warm up and,
and I'm grabbing our fist by, I mean our
hands, like shaking our hands to get,
so he gets strengthened our forearms
and shaking your moons. Those like can,
can we do it and like going like that.
Like, oh, just squeezing walls. Yeah.
We get like, uh, cramps right here. Yeah.
Here's how we're on this fucking big,
too strong. But why not like do like
a risk role where we do that one too,
but I guess I don't know that.
So this style of doing it,
picking each other up and
how weird is this shit?
So was able Sanchez gone with him too?
Or did he, was he focusing on, um,
triple g was in training at that time?
He had a different other
fighters he had to go. Oh, okay.
So he was just in camp.
So then you left Abel Sanchez and
now you're training with, with Manny.
Rob Lives in a state that at the
legends boxing gym in Norwalk.
So that is where you feel like
is your best fit. Yeah, that's,
I'm comfortable right there, you know. Um,
the gym is beautiful
facilities really big. Um,
you have everything that
you need. But for the, um,
Reese Joshua to, uh,
the training camps and to be in the
mountains somewhere private and, you know,
so we could just focus and
get ready for the Mexico.
Nice. Um, did you like
training at altitude?
A big bear was at the first time you
had trained at altitude? No, I kinda,
I went there a few times and
you know, I like it, you know,
the first few weeks is, it was
hard, you know, it was really hard.
He get tired fast and,
um, but I did like it.
But when you come back down to c
level, you, you feel the benefit.
I feel the benefit, the
I ca last more, you know,
more oxygen and your body, your
brain. Yeah, for sure. Now,
um, when you go to Mexico,
do you know what altitude
you're going to be up up there?
There's gonna be high in altitude too
cause there's like a point of diminishing
returns. So people feel like once you
get above like 6,000, 7,000, 8,000,
the idea is that you can't work hard
enough cause there's just not enough air.
Like they think that 5,000
is like the perfect line.
There's a lot of weird
this, this, you know,
people have had different philosophies
when it comes to training at altitude and
now many people feel like you should
actually live at altitude but you should
train at sea level because they think
that you, when you train at sea level,
you could put out more output,
you could do more work and then you go
and live up at altitude so your body
acclimates to the low oxygen and
you develop more red blood cells.
And that makes sense. Yeah.
So we thought about doing something like
that or you're just going to stay up
there. Yeah, I'm just going to stay out
there just for a few months, you know,
and a few months and come back
down, finish, finish it up,
finish the camp for like a month and go
where I'm going to fight that I can say,
well you're in such a great position
man and you're only 29 years old.
So like your athletic prime,
particularly as a heavyweight is like yo
like three or four years away from your
prime, which is really crazy. And
that's a good thing. You know,
I'm still young. I never had big wars.
You know, I never been hurt things to,
you know, and every fight
that I have, you know,
always pray for me and the
guy that I'm fighting. No,
cause I won both of us
who go with our families.
Cause I have two friends that have
died from one, from a heat galleon,
one from Costa Rica that I know
personally. So it's scary man.
It's really scary. It most certainly is.
I mean there's no getting away
from that man. It's, it's,
it's a fucking scares me more.
When you think about your career,
do you have longterm goals?
Do you have like a day that you like a
time where you want to get out of this?
You know what? I wanted to retire
when I was 35 years old and I'm,
I said that on a piece of paper. Like
I like I was telling everybody to,
if you want to join, if you
want a goal or something,
write it down and all that. And I said,
I won't, I wanted to retire when I'm 35.
So we'll see why in 35. I
don't know, I just had it.
That number seems like a good number.
What do you think you would do if you
weren't boxing? Um, do the houses. Mom,
my dad is a contractor. So, uh, we,
we buy lots and we make houses from
scratch and now, and we sell them,
we resell them or we rent
them out and or make, uh,
a lot of apartments, you know,
condos for the people that can
really afford, what was that called?
My Dad does it. Low income
houses, low income houses, um,
apartments like that in my hometown,
you know. Well, that's beautiful.
But for fighters,
the thrill of fighting is something
that is impossible to recreate.
It's almost like for a regular person
to experience what you experienced when
you knocked out Anthony.
Joshua and Joshua gets counted off the
referee waves his arms and you're like,
oh shit. I started jumping like, oh
my God, I grab it. You went nuts, man.
But it'd been that feeling. You, you, you,
all of a sudden you're the heavyweight
champion of the world that, I mean,
if you could sell that, that, look
at that. Look at you right there,
man. I felt like so many stuff, um,
from my bag just came off, you know,
cause so much pressure.
So I'm like, oh yeah, man,
stuff that was going through my
mind. I mean everybody was stunned.
The home crowd was done, everybody
was, but the crowd was on your side.
It was really wild man. When you
routine off on him and that the roars,
the crowd and when it was over,
when the referee just shook
his hand and waved it off,
like that high is what bleeds fighters
back in the ring when they really
shouldn't be. They chase that dragon.
Yeah. And that's what I want to do,
you know, make a statement that
everything is possible. You know,
all the fighters that, that have low
confident or something in themselves,
you know, anything is possible.
Just work hard and know
the opportunity will come.
Do you think you'll ever
train fighters? Me? You know,
I think the only person that will train
would probably be like my son or have
first, you know,
because it's not really good to be
training the son and well it depends what
kind of relationship you guys have,
you know? But, um, I think my son,
I'll be trained. I'd rather be like
a promoter or something like that.
And your mouth promotions. I
like Oscar. I sure will. Yeah.
[inaudible] that's in the
works. Arj Promotion. Oh,
so you're a Knutson. Really?
You're an [inaudible]. Oh, no, shit.
Wow. That's rare. Where that's the plan.
You know, first I want to focus
on the fight and all that.
I don't want to jump in conclusions
of doing all kinds of other stuff.
I want to focus in my flight and um,
after that or when I want to retire,
I want to get fighters from med school,
giving them the opportunity and um,
you know, learn, learn like Oscar the
[inaudible]. Beautiful. That's beautiful,
man. Yeah. Anything else? Anything else
you want to tell people? Um, you know,
just to tune in, uh, December in December.
Anthony Joshua against Andrew Reese
or n or [inaudible] versus Anthony.
Joshua [inaudible]. You're the top
billing now, man. You're the champ.
Thank you. Bye. Um, you know,
uh, just gotta work hard, man.
Work Hard, stay, stay humble. Say
discipline and just focus on the,
on the room match. Well, Andy, listen man,
you're a great guy and a great role
model. Thank you. I appreciate it.
I think for young kids to look up to a
guy like you who's a really nice guy,
who's also a bad motherfucker, it
makes him realize, hey, you know,
you don't have to be a dickhead.
You don't have to be mean.
You can be a real cool dude who even
prays for his opponent and still be the
baddest motherfucker on the
planet. Congratulations to
you, sir. Thank you, man.
Appreciate it very much, and
good luck to you in December,
having meetings coming up.
We're going to be there, man.
I'm going to give you some tickets.
Shit. Oh Shit, man, that'd be there.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].